nel mondo della nuova ricetta regionale
io sono pronto per imbarazzo il nostro
della collina c'è l'olio nascosta di di
studio spiega sade miniera già perché
non ci sia niente di strano problemi
andiamo col sorriso come se non ci
fossero tale ma secchiari qualcosa di
[Risate]
caldo
ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di cucina a bettola siamo qui ad
interim ad un catechista
ciao ragazzi ben tornati alla prima
puntata di benvenuti ciao ragazzi e
benvenuti alla prima puntata di cucina
bettola il format di cugina del cuore
con cin in un posto orribile oggi
prepareremo però per fortuna un piatto
veramente delizioso la tempura di
gamberi vediamo subito quali sono gli
ingredienti
purtroppo abbiamo avuto dei problemi per
dei lavori che stanno venendo fatti
nell'altra cucina e quindi potuto
trovare un altro posto del quale
lavorare ne abbiamo pensato i vari
nessuno andava bene questo era il meglio
che siamo riusciti a ottenere
immaginatevi che cos'è l'altra roba
l'importante non è tanto la forma e
parliamone ah scusate che sono rischio
non è la forma ma la sostanza così come
in un piatto non è importante la
bellezza ma il sapore ecco perché mi
deve venire da dio questo piatto per
fare la tempura di gambe come la fanno i
giapponesi
avremo bisogno di olio di arachidi uovo
amido di mais farina
vodka acqua frizzante che al momento
stiamo tenendo in frigo perché da essere
freddissima e infine gamberi non si
facciamo li vedete non ho mai toccato
dei camper i che rimangono addosso i
gamberi questa ricetta e per 12 che a me
ne abbiamo esattamente 12
ringrazio anche il disegnatore di dragon
dai perché senza quei fumetti a
quest'ora non avrei un tavolo di 10
centimetri più alto per prima cosa
iniziamo a sgusciare i gamberi di testa
in teoria se siete un minimo
intelligenti non le buttate nel cestino
ma le usate e poi per fare un brodino di
pesce un qualcosa di simile scocciare
gambe ricordandosi però di lasciare la
comoda se ti rendi conto sto parlando di
meno ci sono meno tipo ciao ragazze
molto più intimo fa così tanto schifo
cioè non stavo chiedendo voi voi che
state guardando dall'altra parte serio
rischio si va bene sapere qua sotto
se è veramente così osceno perché se è
veramente così osceno è che mi sono
andato a cucinare con la carta parte ma
facciamo un salto temporanea quando li
avrò sbucciate vai già boom
niente alla fine avremo una roba così in
quindi tutto questo bel color di gamberi
che personalmente mi mangiare così
perché non amo i gamberi cotti e
impazzisco per quelli crudi di ghiaccio
in frigo e nel frattempo metto l'olio in
pentola e aspetto che si riscaldi cosa
certo mentre aspettiamo che l'olio vada
in temperatura dobbiamo misurare le
seguenti cose la farina e l'amido di
mais per la farina abbiamo bisogno posso
dire una cosa comunque c'è compratele
questo due tazze di farina 00
una due e mezza tazza di amido di mais
a questo punto prendiamo gli ingredienti
secchi e uniamo lì
difetti però sono liquidi prendiamo la
farina la maizena e uniamo le nell'altra
ciotola a prendere la vodka o un
bicchiere invitation di chi tocca
sentire dice un bicchiere vodka e nuovo
che cosa vorrei peel hunt dice si porta
sopra non proprio mentre lo stavo per
fare le rese conto che non è che fossero
l'idea migliore e assoluto iniziamo
unirli no acqua dei piatti
ho bisogno di un'assistenza da vicino la
barca non visibile notti si vede in
pieno acqua frizzante molto molto molto
fredda ecco qua infatti all'ultimo se
dovete fare mi raccomando alcun chiamo
spostiamoci qui enrico occhio mica
scappa in occhi
che schifo prendiamo un gambero lo
immergiamo nella pastella per bene con
te lo devi tenere 23 minuti ha aggiunto
della farina cosa cavolo o no no lascia
così lascia forse deve essere leggera
leggera un bicchiere della rocca secco
la nato
non mi sembra la tempura ci sono delle
cose non mi tornano di questa avventura
vivo questa tempura core ix ces tanti ne
andò a fare un impianto mento figo fanno
pur meno liti tutti gourmet eccolo per
me prima considerazione la pastella è un
botto di consiglio per evitare di
sprecarla tutta quanta di fare almeno
altri 24
gamberi o dimezzare le porzioni solo che
non so bene come dimezzare un uovo
nota di demerito per la cucina e per le
ricette online che ti spingono a
sprecare in questo modo detto ciò questo
è il mio piatto ed è venuto molto più
carino di quello che pensassi
come faremo fuori ad assaggiare
massaggio posso dire carmen è
stranamente gustoso un aspettava
sapessero di merda sinceramente anche
meglio
secondo facciamo il prodotto un cinese
qua sono meno atroce dovevi fare una
pastella nel migliore dei modi questo è
un po un sito dove già da quest'anno
ancora la pinna pastella e diversa però
poi da quella classica ma non so che del
tipo fiori di zucca questa non è più
fritturina più leggera di quella del no
no intendo tipo frittura di pesce del
genere da questo sta indicando cucina ha
detto la cucina bettola potrebbe dare
delle soddisfazioni
siamo arrivati alla fine di questa
puntata un po speciale nel senso il
brutto del termine vi chiediamo scusa se
siamo finiti di questo tugurio credo che
nelle prossime settimane ci ritorneremo
se vi è piaciuto questo video mette temi
un pollice in su per il iscrivetevi al
canale attivate la campanella delle
notifiche ma soprattutto ci vediamo
domenica prossima sempre 12 con un altro
episodio di cucina buttata cioè telai
mangiatine arrangiati con tira ci ho
messo tanto a parlare sono me non era un
lo dici contarino 10 e 12